[Música]
provavelmente eu estou aqui hoje porque
eu sou um insatisfeito e me explicar
rapidamente porque não é exatamente
sobre mim
a fala mas desde sempre
eu tive comigo que eu queria a vida
inteira me sentir realizando e nunca me
sentir realizado e talvez a minha
trajetória seja um depoimento sobre isso
sempre que eu me sentia conquistado por
algo ou tendo conquistado algo eu
pensava qual é o próximo passo a dar não
por desmerecer aquela conquista mas por
perceber que era possível e além
e foi assim que eu me tornei um
engenheiro de engenheiro professor e
hoje trabalho com web aulas ea gente vai
discutir aqui um pouco sobre a escola e
sobre algo que eu fiz pensando talvez em
contribuir com elas mas eu queria pra
começar que vocês observassem
atentamente essa foto é pujante
é impossível não perceber a alegria
dessas crianças
né talvez porque ela representa
austeridade do mestre ali representado
mas veja que tem uma pimentinha aqui
para salvar o c
sempre tem uma festinha na sala e é
interessante que a gente olha para esse
tipo de foto e sorrir
muitas vezes porque a gente se percebe
distante dessa realidade no tempo é
verdade a gente está distante mas será
que quando a gente vê uma sala moderna
como essa com estudantes sorridentes
a gente realmente está vendo estudantes
felizes pra provocar uma reflexão eu
queria convidar o escritor e jurista e
diplomata e poeta maranhense raimundo
correia que diz em mal secreto se a
cólera que espuma dor que mora na alma e
destrói cada ilusão que nasce tudo que
puxe tudo que devora o coração no rosto
se estã passe
se se pudesse o espírito que chora ver
através da máscara da face
quanta gente talvez que inveja agora nos
causa então piedade nos causasse quanta
gente que ri talvez consigo guardar um
atroz recôndito inimigo como invisível
chadha cancerosa quanta gente que ri
talvez existe cuja aventura única
consiste em parecer aos outros venturoso
é bem duro isso é muito duro isso e eu
enquanto o professor ii
na minha época trabalho infantil é crime
então eu tenho quase 25 anos de sala de
aula eu tenho más notícias a distância
daquela primeira foto para os dias de
hoje é muito mais temporal do que
qualquer outro tipo de distância
em algum momento e eu tenho pesquisado
sobre isso mas não tenho certeza ainda
mas em algum momento a escola deixa de
ser um lugar legal para aí eu me lembro
enquanto criança como é legal me arrumar
eu não cheguei mesmo a minha mochila e
correu para a escola mas em algum
momento esse brilho esse encanto se
perde a gente passa até aquela crise do
da vinheta do fantástico ainda estudante
quando domingo de noite a gente escuta o
fantástico sabe segunda feira tem aula
será que é porque o nosso modelo de
escola se aproxima de um presídio
se você observar são pessoas que estão
informatizadas que escutam a sirene que
se encaminham para pequenas células
será porque os estudantes e professores
estão presos em grades exatamente em
grades gradis de conteúdo ok mas são
grades no sentido de que aprisionam
porque alunos e professores são
aprisionados a uma rotina de aulas de
estudos que muitas vezes estão
completamente desconectadas da realidade
do estudante e dos objetivos que eles
têm muito distante do cotidiano deles e
talvez esse seja um grande problema para
causados interesse
se vocês me permitirem eu quero fazer
uso de uma história que aconteceu comigo
e que representa muito disso que eu
disse eu não sei se vocês reconhecem
todos que estão aí mas o primeiro é rock
rádio som um ator famoso de hollywood o
tom cruise da década de 60 ao lado tom
hanks freddy mercury e caso
na década de 80 quando eu era
adolescente no começo da adolescência na
segunda metade da década de 80 nas
morreu rock hard sun complicações
relativas à aids nessa mesma época tom
hanks ganhava o seu primeiro óscar
representando um advogado perseguido por
ser soropositivo no filme filadélfia
estávamos muito muito perto de perdermos
um dos maiores vocalistas de bandas de
rock já tiveram na história do rock e
prestes a descobrir que cazuza também
era soropositivo
e aí vezes e aí que nessa época eu fui
obrigado no terceiro ano
a saber chegar numa farmácia por exemplo
pedir por gentileza quatro drágeas de
matilla menor fininho demitiu pina zona
de novo de matilla menor fenil dimetil
pela zona tive que aprender isso em
química orgânica
isso aí é o composto químico básico da
sybase lena eo meu professor de química
entendi que podia ser útil na prova do
vestibular né
e já que era para exercitar a memória
porque não fazer a nova usar aplique nem
um time de neco que é de trás pra frente
só para me mostrar
aí você me pergunta pois o que é que se
baleia até a ver com a aids
nada mas se você me der mais um minuto
da sua atenção você vai entender onde eu
quero chegar e para você entender onde
eu quero chegar
eu preciso contar o que aconteceu poucos
meses depois de aprender esse palavrão
já aprovado em engenharia na federal
ainda recuperando os cabelos perdidos
por conta da aprovação eu descobri
veraneando o quanto você pode ser sexy
se você for aprovado em engenharia da
federal
e aí eu precisei procurar proteção
lembra que eu era adolescente já se
falava de artes e aí fui a uma farmácia
me lembro bem como hoje entrando
extremamente constrangido ao balcão no
cantinho do balcão chamando o rapaz como
quem vai pedir drogas ilícitas e
cochichando moço por favor
o senhor tem contraceptivo masculino o
cara na praia de vera nem olhou pra
minha cara e fez em e aí eu disse
contraceptivo com don airey correu à
vista assim na farmácia condon é uma
marca disse não não não não
respirei fundo engolir a vergonha e
disse eu quero camisa de vênus
aí ele olhou pra mim e disse ah ah ah aí
virou para o lado do balcão onde só
fulano traz camisinha que o gordinho vai
dar uma mais tarde e ver o que é isso
isso é desconexão da escola com a
realidade
ela me ensinava decorar de maxilar menor
fenil demitiu pela zona e não ensinava
comprar camisinha não é porque se morria
por conta de complicações das isso é a
mensagem
a escola estava desconectada da minha
época será que isso mudou
quantas vezes eu viajar pelo país
falando sobre e nem sobre outras coisas
quantas vezes eu vejo nas escolas esse
símbolo proibido o uso do celular e o
quanto isso me angustia porque sou da
área de tecnologia eu sei por exemplo
que alguns dos nossos celulares possuem
a tecnologia mais sofisticada do que
aquela que 69 levou o homem para a lua
então parti lua
só que não na escola você não pode pegar
uma ferramenta tecnológica como ela vai
fazer uso é proibido o uso do celular
será que o erro é o uso do celular e aí
de novo me permitam né investigar as
reminiscências do pretérito como meu pai
gostava de dizer tabuada
eu sei que muitos aqui são jovens talvez
não tenham passado pela tortura de fazer
argüições sobre a tabuada
eu escapei da bolacha mas eu levei
resguardo da minha mãe em casa pra
decorar a tabuada principalmente a de
multiplicar me perturbava tinha uma
coisa que era terrível que era que a
professora mandava a gente memorizar e
quando ela perguntava por exemplo 7 16
eu que tinha uma memória 17 16 42
professora e ela ficava irritada porque
ela dizia o menino de sua resposta
porque fica repetindo a pergunta aí o
bicho tinha colorado então era feito um
jogral perguntou dizia tudo tanto que é
preciso desenvolver uma técnica sei
quantas 7652 professora né pra aparecer
um pouquinho mais inteligente contar nos
dedos
meu deus que loucura é claro que não na
minha época o dia acho que hoje ainda
não pode
os dedos era um recurso tecnológico e
para mostrar que é um recurso
tecnológico
eu paro aqui a apresentação e peço para
que todo mundo coloca as duas mãos de
frente para o rosto assim eu vou
explicar para vocês a tabuada de
multiplicar mais difícil que é de 9
vamos fazer agora 196 continua sua
esquerda para a direita os dedos até o
sexto e quando chegar no sexto dobre
esse dedo 123456 os dedos que sobraram
antes são a dezena 50 aquilo que sobrou
depois da unidade 54 e as fazem o ró
isidro que só serve com esse não faz
nove vezes oito 12345678 baixou que fica
antes 7 o que fica depois 2 72 aires mas
também só pode usar até 10 não faz nove
vezes 15
um dois três quatro cinco seis dez anos
o pé não conta de novo um 12345 10 11 12
13 14 15 dobrou
como você já usou as duas mãos uma vez
inteiras e para um e aí você fica com a
centena 135
o delegado então eu espero que vocês
entendam que o problema não é a
tecnologia é o mau uso dela
a gente precisa criar estratégias para
usar de forma correta tecnologia e aí é
onde entra a plataforma de ensino que
hoje muita gente fala sobre plataforma
de ensino à plataforma de ensino
ela não precisa ser um concorrente da
escola tradicional mas a escola
tradicional tem um grande problema na
sua origem
a gente tem um modelo de escola que é
prosseguir ano
a gente funciona mais ou menos como se
fosse uma linha de produção as crianças
entram na caixinha recebe um monte de
informação vão para outra caixinha
recebe um monte de informação como se
fosse uma linha de produção industrial é
um modelo fabril
o grande problema é que você junta às
crianças como se elas fossem iguais
aprendessem de formas iguais
tem um grande grande problema serão 11
anos não são iguais e por isso a melhor
forma é customizar a educação apresentar
os conteúdos de acordo com o interesse
dentro de objetivos claros mas
personalizando a apresentação e o grande
problema da escola física que ela não
tem condição de atender um a um dos seus
alunos personalizando e customizando as
explicações à escola física não a web
tem ea conta ou a produção de conteúdo
têm se tornado cada vez mais barato e
abundante o que permite supor que muito
em breve a gente vai conseguir
e essa é uma das metas do youtube
educação por exemplo que cada estudante
aprenda o seu ritmo do seu jeito
o lema é todas as formas de ensinar a
sua forma de aprender e onde é que eu e
visa entrou no meio dessa história toda
eu entro com o projeto chamado física
total que tem o pequeno desafio de ser
uma ferramenta de apresentação do
conteúdo de física de forma agradável
interessante eu escutei um a significa
que ela não conhece meu canal agradável
interessante e eficiente
não é só para ser divertido não é para
funcionar e aprender
e aí eu tenho um grande desafio o meu
desafio é vencer as desigualdades no
ensino de física no nosso país
possibilitará qualquer estudante que
queira de fato aprender física ter essa
oportunidade comigo e eu me aproprio da
capilaridade da rede só para falar de
alguns números
isso aconteceu em 2015
nós tivemos no nosso canal pouco mais de
4 milhões 200 mil aulas assistidas
o que em tempo significa um pouco mais
de 20 mil 9 29 milhões de minutos a
gente convertesse isso na hora aula
padrão de 45 minutos seriam mais de
650.000 aulas que divididas em 40
semanas letivas de 40 aulas semanais se
vida tivesse para tanto eu precisei
precisaria de 406 anos e 11 meses para
repetir essa brincadeira
só que na internet a gente tem uma uma
situação a parte em que cada minuto
nosso rende cerca de 3 mil
uma aula física então na verdade o que
eu consegui
eu precisaria de quase mil e duzentos
anos na escola física pra fazer só com
que eu conquistei no ano passado
na minha época deixar um legado é alguma
coisa como escrever um livro ter um
filho plantar uma planta plantar uma
árvore mais perto disse que eu fiz da
planta um grãozinho de feijão e ver
aquela história de decote letônia achar
que eu era uma forma de divindade que
criava vida e fica frustrado uma semana
depois quando ele morrer um algodãozinho
esqueceram dizer que eu tenho transferir
para a areia
bom mas hoje o meu trabalho virtual eu
posso morrer e continuar ajudando as
pessoas tentam sempre é assim mas eu
posso continuar
eu acho que isso é transcendência
eu conquistei isso a partir do trabalho
e eu tenho a possibilidade de levar o
mesmo conteúdo pra gente como aquelas
pessoas que moram no aldebaran nos
jardins em são paulo e estudantes de uma
tribo indígena e isso é verdade esses
dois públicos me assistem hoje
se isso não é revolucionário não sei
dizer o que é quando essas crianças que
já estão por aí espalhadas em nas
escolas elas estiverem maiores elas não
vão aceitar ser peças tratadas como
peças na linha de produção e é isso me
lembra muito um clipe de uma banda de
rock revolucionária pra mim chamada pink
floyd em que um dos versos da sua música
talvez mais famosa
ele grita ele não canta a letra em que
diz a lom que não há tradução moderna eu
diria
deixe as crianças seguirem seu próprio
caminho
a tecnologia permite que cada uma dessas
crianças construa sua aprendizagem
mediada por professores preparados e
engajados com esse tipo de movimento é
possível sim personalizar e cada uma das
crianças seguir o seu caminho um país
eu sei que é um desafio tentarmos mudar
a educação
e eu sei que esse papel parte de nós
como foi tão bem falado na primeira
parte começa em você
então eu proponho a você mas como um
desafio
repense a sua postura em relação à
escola dos seus filhos
questione amigos professores diretores
sobre a inserção da tecnologia no
ambiente escolar provoque os provoco se
participe de informativa dessa mudança
não é simples mas como lema que eu
carrego no peito e aprendi muito cedo em
casa quando você se cerca das pessoas
que potencializam as suas habilidades e
acredita firmemente no seu propósito
todas as metas são conquistar weiss
l quem vp lembre que você pode mudar sua
sala de aula a sua escola a educação do
seu país
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]